hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
we don't go and answer a question from
one of my forum readers Jason he was
nude or forums and I asked him if
there's anything we can help him with
and he basically wrote back this long
forum post here which was great and
asked me to check out his website so
here it is it's rise online and jason is
a success coach and one of my thoughts
on you know what I thought about his
site so first of all it's a really
competitive market that you're involved
in here so I see you've got your picture
which is great you've got this video
it's really hard to stand out right
there's so many eight success coaches
I'm going to let this play out see if
something catches my eye while rousing
success there's so many guys who are
doing what you do you have to find a way
to stand out and be different but and
I'm not seeing that here on your site so
it's this course no it's a game changer
not for everyone next name you know
learn the foundation success skills and
succeed it's not I'm not see anything
here that I could think is unique to you
compared to all the other schools
everybody's saying the same for right so
if I went entrepreneur and I come across
want you 20 different success coaches a
lot of them have the exact same message
mean so you have to really stand out and
we different and you I see a lot of that
personality come out on the forms but it
only see it happening here there's a
little bit on the video but not so much
on your site so i try to incorporate a
little bit more of you on trying to this
website the next thing i'm gonna look at
is i'm looking for a success coach I
want to see how successful have you been
before I don't want to see what your
background is and learn a little bit
more before you've done you're the kind
of guy that I want to look up to hung in
a higher success coach so the plan says
here talk to you by genuine IQ guys when
seven years in failure been the victim
of us have betrayed more of a smile
they're safe hover to learn more about
me to succeed
no not entirely easy to read button
success coach lady guys sexy success
Jesus I'm working people feel so eager
to get success and is committed to it
classics what I what I'm curious to do
is what have you done that's what I want
to know so what business have you start
up what do you define a success how do
you consider yourself to be successful
maybe it's going through all these
challenges and still being having a
smile at the end of it but I want to
know a little bit more about you and
your background because I'm going to
sign up for your poor so I would expand
this someone say not talk about so many
kind of general things but more
specifics and bring out a little more
about your background I will make people
want to learn more about you and with
decision making actually I like to have
a testimonial it's always great to have
some kind of proof here to show that
what you're doing is working and helping
people it's a great testimonial to what
I would suggest is see if you can get a
picture of this person but it and also
link off to their website so benefits
them but also it shows that this is a
real person because a lot of people just
put in with great testimonials when I
put it we're going to want we don't know
who this Tony totori person is so
sleeping at a pictures here you can link
off to the site to again bring home
incredibly a little bit more sense a
jumpstart I like that you've shown that
you're featured on these different media
outlets it's great it shows that you're
kind of beyond just brand new start up
but in all honesty not a lot of these
guys are really good name as much as I
love Danny and fire pole marketing these
guys aren't really brand name sites that
helping people will recognize what I
would suggest is trying to get into the
media and it's not that hard an easy way
is to subscribe to service i use called
PR leads and basically reporters put out
requests for experts and you could be
that expert like for every story those
reporters seinem you know are looking
for people to comment provided expert
analysis so why can't you be that expert
so look for pure leads is a paid service
you can look at other ones you can build
your own media list try to get in some
mainstream media and that will make this
pop a little bit more
so people who don't know what putty-like
is or eco centric and I've never heard
of these ones before then that helps you
stand a little bit more I mean this is
great it's better than not having
anything but I try to up my game a
little bit more and have brands a little
bit more recognized something that is
how confusing here i was looking at this
testimonial and this is a finished part
11 of your lessons and loved at all it's
great and then you say here that it's a
10 lesson ecorse so what is it is it 11
lessons or is it 10 lessons you know
maybe there's some extra lesson at the
end that you don't tell people about
maybe you can have this person change a
testimonial to 10 just so that you know
there's not this discrepancy if I see
mistakes on a website then I'm probably
not going to want to sign up so see if
you can get that change if you can the
other thing is your call to action here
that I'm looking at it says will contact
you personally to start you on your 10
lesson ecorse to the skills of the
world's most legendary so there's you've
got some grammatical issues in here so
your 10 lesson ecorse to maybe learn the
skills of the most legendary you know
you could leave it there it's kind of
hanging you want wanted you know add
something else on there but at least fix
this part up because again you see
Graham grammatical mistake you're not
going to want to sign up so that should
help you boost your conversions as well
finally the last thing I noticed on your
your forum post here you said here are
love more people to take me up in the
consultation because once I connect with
someone I deliver massive value is all
some benefits and they love me forever
grin and I find this the same with my
business as well and I start working
with a client I've worked more with big
corporate clients but we usually I
started with something small and maybe
you can there's a thin wedge you can get
in here to start off something low risk
now working with a success coach can be
something scary people don't know if
they really need a success coach or how
much is it going to cost or you know how
to get started if you make that first
step really easy and low risk then
they're more likely going to want to do
it and once they talk to you on the
phone or skype or
it then the more likely to as you say
wanna you know love you and and start up
with you forever so I try to find a
low-risk way for people to start doing
business with you and get to know you
beyond just your your newsletter your e
course and then you can show them all
the benefits that you're providing with
them so when I start working with a
corporate client we usually start off
with one small job and over-deliver like
crazy drive lots of people to the post
do way more than what they thought and
they could come back they always come
back want when you do more and more and
more with them and ends up being a great
relationship so it starts off starting
small if I went in with a huge package
from the start it's going to be a lot
harder to sell them then if I go in with
a easy package for them to say yes to
they get comfortable working with me
they see the results are coming in then
they're much more willing to go and
spend bigger dollars so Jason I hope
that helps good luck with the site if
you guys liked the video please give it
a thumbs up below I'd also love to hear
what you have to think about Jason site
and what you're doing with your websites
if you want to leave a comment below and
stay tuned for next episode
you